Anthony thanks for joining us clear up
the past couple of days here for
baseball fans it's been a an interesting
past couple of days for Mets fans
anyways you know Matt Harvey didn't show
up to the ballpark on Saturday that is a
big no-no in baseball culture and he did
show up Sunday and was told to go home
he was scheduled to pitch the Mets said
no you're not going to pitch you're
suspended for three days and you know it
became what it became this kind of
collection of looking back on old Matt
Harvey's transgressions over the years
and there are several and it just became
this look into his character so it
provides him to the medicine to what he
is now you know post two surgeries
struggling and certainly he's at a stage
in his career where he needs to be on
his best behavior and he is not doing
that so the Mets suspended him and
that's where we stand today did Harvey
tried to tell the team that he wasn't
going to be there yeah so apparently
from Harvey's end there was a bit of a
miscommunication and and telling them
that she wasn't going to be there on
Saturday and either they didn't
understand her the message didn't get
through but from the Mets end this was a
clear transgression and this was a this
wasn't an excused absence
so when Matt Harvey did show up to the
ballpark on Sunday and the word of
Harvey's camp appears to me that he had
some migraines on Saturday whatever the
excuse you want to go with whatever the
excuse may be again it wasn't excused at
so when he showed up on Sundays and
that's where none too pleased and
obviously they wouldn't be if you're
going to suspend a guy for three days
and this wasn't just a regular
suspension this is a suspension of a guy
who was supposed to pitch that day so it
kind of threw everything into disarray
for the Mets you've got Adam will ka
triple a journeyman flying across the
country from Las Vegas - he went to
Denver to Albuquerque then to LA and
then to New York landed 9:00 in the
morning all so that he could pitch in
place of Matt Harvey wound up getting
shelled the Marlins 170 now
things so this was a definitely a
difficult decision for the Mets to
stomach and they stood their ground and
they suspended Matt Harvey so whatever
is a reason might be that he didn't show
up and you know we're going to get a lot
more answers on end when he does come
back to the tomorrow this is again not
an excuse desk and something that the
Mets are very very angry about but I'm
looking at Matt Harvey he's a 500
pitcher he's had two surgeries I think
he enjoys all the fruits of being in New
York and being a it's like he's a
celebrity just not a great baseball
pitcher anymore
well what was what do you say is that a
fair assessment of Man Harvey
well I'm who we're actually talking
about the other day and his career
record is 31 and 30 like you said and I
think that's shocking to some people who
know him only as quote/unquote the Dark
Knight and this persona that has been
created for him over the past few years
and he really hasn't been that guy since
2015 and coming back from from Tommy
John surgery I think he exceeded a lot
of expectations he had a good full year
and went into the playoffs and was on
the mound in the ninth inning of a World
Series game with a lead and since that
time he really struggled last he wound
up having surgery to repair that
thoracic outlet syndrome which was
causing numbness in his hands up his arm
and he hasn't been the same since he
came to spring training he looks ok not
great and he has been not great
throughout the early season here so yeah
like you said this is a guy whose
persona is still the picture that we all
remember from 2013 and he's not that guy
and he hasn't been that guy for several
years and yet he still goes out and he
still finds his way into the tabloids
and he still finds his his way onto page
6 a New York Post and all that stuff and
it's an act that I think people were a
lot more willing to tolerate back when
he was on top of the world on the
baseball diamond because frankly that's
the reason this guy got famous in the
first place I'll leave you with this the
sex toy that was found in his locker
that showed up on social media does that
play any role in this
plays no role in this that has been made
made very clear that was a a prank it
was a prank that spread like wildfire
but I know Matt Harvey had nothing to do
with it
I apologize even asking that Anthony
okay alright thanks for thanks for
joining us and I'm sure it will be
eventful when Harvey comes back thank
you for joining us Anthony you got it
Anthony Tacoma
the immense reporter mlb.com the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience